nope nope yes yes yes yes oh my god  you're beautiful  yes where's the H and M says three  minutes and watch out cuz there's a  police officer spotted ahead okay  you are gonna be designated driver next  I will next time I will  Oh how much farther is this in a now  we've been driving for like 20 minutes  it's 4 hours and 38 minutes away what  we're gonna go to Vegas please where are  you where in the world are they  excuse me have you seen my keys have you  seen my keys are they I'm gonna get us  an uber you know maybe we should just  walk really so nice I was like crazy be  crazy not to do it all right I'm gonna  give us an uber I could walk I could  even walk enough like that oh [ __ ] 5  times surge pricing Oh crazy let's be  crazy I feel crazy oh great  are you okay nice please bad feel a  diffuse batch yes oh come on  on yes yes if we met I would show you  such a good time  I was hoping for you buy all the oysters  you want